I found out that I was being imminent
domained by the author of a news article
that was coming out that day they called
me he called me up in the morning and
said I'm publishing a uh an article
today from the city of San Antonio
saying they're going to vote imminent
domain you next week at the city council
meeting I had eight days and three
minutes to talk in front of council to
to try to save my business and my
property and everything that I've been
working for the last 15 years
I'm Vince Cantu I'm the owner of Moses
Rose's Bar and Grill big government's
trying to take my property and uh I I
think that's wrong and I'm here to talk
about it some downtown San Antonio I'm a
half block from the Alamo
um so it's already in a really really
great spot but they're about to put a
600 million dollar Museum next to me so
Inlet domain is when a government
decides they need your property and if
you don't want to sell it or they don't
in my case if they don't like the price
that they that I have on it then they
can move in and condemn it and take it
from you
um they appraised it at today's value so
the current status of um my situation
with the state of Texas and the city of
San Antonio is
um
we've sort of entered into a Emmett
domain phase where the the protocol is
is that they give me a first offer this
is how all Emma domain Works in Texas
anyway they give me a first offer called
the initial offer even though I've
already had five offers this is Emmett
domain law and uh then by Statute they
have to wait 30 more days before they
give me the final offer and then if I
refuse both those offers
um and we don't come to some sort of
settlement then they file a lawsuit 14
days later
by Statute they can't do it before that
they can do it after that they cannot do
it at all but I mean by Statute they
have to give it at least 14 days follow
a lawsuit against me to condemn my
property and then that goes in front of
three judges arbitrators really the way
it works in Texas
so right now we're in between the
initial offer and the final offer about
halfway in between I've been working
with the state to try to uh to try to
negotiate a price that would uh to me be
fair to me and my family
the value of my property is going to
Skyrocket this property is all around me
are going to Skyrocket because it's the
biggest attraction they've built
downtown San Antonio in 100 years you
know almost so I want the I want the
future value as well as today's value if
I'm going to walk away from it because
to me it's a represents a generational
property it's a property that I can run
the rest of my life whether I want to
work there or not I could just lease it
out to a Starbucks or to a franchise
that wants to be right there by the
Alamo my kids could have it as well in
their family and it could be producing
generational wealth for my whole family
for you know for forever really as long
as there's an Alamo
a lot of people have asked for uh for
you know answer to that you know what
are you asking for what's what's the
number and uh it is awkward because or
you know normally you wouldn't be
um negotiating this in the press or you
know uh openly like this and um
but the state of Texas they published
the number that I asked for initially
they asked me for a number three three
and a half years ago
um and I told them I would sell for 10
million dollars for the property five
million dollars for the business and
that was kind of like my starting point
that was where we uh my wife and I
decided we'd start but they never
responded to that and uh like two years
after we gave them that number the first
time they ever responded to it was in
the paper saying oh this guy wants 15
million dollars oh he wants 17 million
dollars now
um he won't he won't negotiate he you
know we're at an impasse because he
wants too much money
if you combine it with my business as
well as my property because I own both
the real estate and the business that's
inside of it
um I would you know definitely say that
the business is going to be worth around
4 million and the property is going to
be worth over 5 million if you look out
five and ten years from now and my
neighbor who doesn't own any property he
leases Elisa's uh property from the
state was bought out of his lease he had
five years left on his lease and the
state gave him 10 million dollars
4 million is a nice start for sure it's
a lot of money I'm not denying that but
um it's it's not 10 million and the guy
that that got 10 million didn't even own
property so I think that um they should
be treating me with the kind of respect
and um
honor that that my neighbor got
um so I'm going to fight for that